[Music]
boolean cap podcast
we got chappelle is this repel lacy yeah
chappelle lacy harris no you see you
know me
that's how long you've known me so now
it's okay we have the
world famous world famous stand-up
comedian
chapelle lacy i say a couple states
chappelle lacy is here so uh for people
who don't know
uh that's so wild you know my real i
mean it's not what do you mean it's wild
you're the [ __ ] high school together
but it's just weird to hear it because
no one
no one like knows that knows me as that
yeah so
me and chappelle went to uh we went to
westwood high together
in mesa and
uh war eagle shout out to the warriors
man
uh yeah and like it's cool because like
when we were in school we were cool the
whole time
yeah i feel like we were kind of like
kindred spirits low-key we uh
we met and uh that teacher's name was
miss sarwark
oh wow but i don't remember what the
class was i remember that name though
yeah miss sarwark and she was kind of
i mean she would go hard on us i think
just because we was you know
sorry i should google her i know i can't
remember i seen her face actually this
was like
some like development like
type class i don't know exactly what it
was
i keep wanting to say humanities but it
wasn't humanity it might have been uh
there was something along that line
those lines hold on let's see star wars
it's our work
let's see if i could find her miss our
work
yeah teacher westwood westwood
short little lady with red hair i think
something like that with glasses
ah she ain't on here she ain't on there
yeah her career didn't last that long
probably
probably not i don't know i mean if
she's not on
did you ever did we have mr green's
class ever together which one was mr oh
the
history he's a history guy no we didn't
have mr green i never had mr green he
was fired yeah that was
like the chill dude yeah i feel like he
was like getting high with students
that's what everybody says that's
that was like i feel like that was like
folklore though everybody would say that
about like
miss roundtree yeah we had miss
roundtree that [ __ ] was turned up yeah
miss roundtree was turned up we had miss
roundtree
shut up fire
i used to write people's essays in that
class oh for real yeah
well she was english right english yeah
yeah miss roundtree was fire
yeah that's crazy so okay so we met in
high school
and you you know it was interesting
because
at our school there was like as we went
to school with some mormons
yeah because we was in mesa mm-hmm we
went to school some native american
folks yup
and then there was like the you know
westwood is kind of like a nice gumbo
pot of
mesa arizona yeah right because the
reservation
that's like the core of the raise the
res is there
around the school it's kind of hood
low-key and then like then there's just
mormons because it's mesa mormons
we got a bunch of tongans yeah but like
it was it was crazy because you were
always like people always loved you in
school
um and i feel like i knew your brother
rest in peace too
yeah yeah yeah me and your brother were
cool i forget i think we had weight
training together and he was always
super successful
he he always said great things about you
yeah he all the time but uh
yeah it was it was crazy because you
were this black kid in high school
who would wear these tight ass pants and
these punk rock t-shirts
i still do right no no no but i just
remember like being like yo
like like who is this guy like this [ __ ]
is kind of dope but you also were in the
hip hop too
like that's what i said one of one of my
favorite memories of you
uh was when
when odb died you printed out a bunch of
pictures
of odb that and and put uh type yeah
typed rest in peace
odb and you taped him all over
the school yeah i remember that clearly
that's one of my favorite memories of
you
yeah man shout out to old dirty bastard
yeah i remember that when that happened
because i took one of the uh because i
love wu-tang obviously right
and uh i took one of the papers or
whatever and i had it in my folder
forever
yeah shout out to odb man yeah yeah i
felt like uh at school like i was like
the music nerd dude and yeah you you you
were like the music nerd on the other
stuff
on the other stuff on the rock and then
bruh
okay i'm trying to think if this is
where you got your name
okay because i was selling cds back then
and donuts
and donuts ah yes bro
he used to come to school with a duffel
bag and it was so funny he would sell
him
but you would hook me up all the time
yeah he should just throw them to me for
free
yeah but everybody else he had a duffel
bag full of music
like don't intimates yeah my mom was the
manager entenmann's on by fiesta mall so
all the stuff that they were gonna throw
out which i would just take and then i
would sell it at school two bucks
dude he was selling i'd be posting up at
lunchtime
duffel bag the whole big old i had it
was a big ass duffle bag
yeah so i was like and then the longer
the day would go on and the donuts were
still there like the box would get more
[ __ ] up and i'd have to give them to
him like oh look i got this box that's
busted open
yeah yeah i used to do that all the time
bro yeah man
that's crazy so crazy yeah so
uh we went to high school together
for people who don't know you've been
how you've been doing stand-up for how
long
how long i've been doing eight or nine
years or something like that
i didn't even know you've been doing it
that long yeah most people don't because
because i had you moved out of arizona
right after my brother had passed i
stopped
okay that was uh he he died in 2013
and then i s in all of 2014 and 2015
i didn't do it and then 2016 was when i
got back in it
wow so you pau you had moved out of
arizona right weren't you living like
somewhere random or yeah oh yeah when i
was uh yeah cause i cheered
you were doing cheerleading stuff in
college and touring and yeah
uh where'd you go to college i went to a
school in texas called trinity
texas yeah and then uh university of
louisville in kentucky
yeah and that's another random thing you
were you know
a cheerleader like a like a brilliant
cheerleader yeah
that's the thing that caught everybody's
[ __ ] ninja this guy was like
a hardcore punk rocker yeah who also was
a cheerleader
at the same time let me tell you bro i
didn't go [ __ ] about anybody
yeah it was it was crazy i did what i
did man
and i was like i got to be good at it if
i sucked at it
then it'd be like everybody's just gonna
make it can you still do flips
yeah that's fire yeah yeah it's not like
riding a bike
so like um you know i'm
we went to high school together you
graduate you do the cheerleading thing
very successful with that by the way
yeah um yeah i'm your scholarship and
all that [ __ ]
and then uh got me a scholarship to drop
out i tell you that much too
i feel like the stand-up thing is like
it's like you know
it's it's almost like i feel like loki
is kind of like the hip-hop game there's
so many people who do stand up in
whatever city you're in they go to open
mics
yes and they they say like it sounds
good to say yeah i'm a stand-up comedian
or whatever i do stand up
but like to actually take it serious and
and move your life to la and like really
pursue it like what was the thing that
made you
take that leap like was there a specific
thing that happened like
yeah i was uh i was working at a hotel
in phoenix
and this was 2017 you know you know like
i said
like and i had been back you know been
back in comedy for like a year
and uh you know 2017 i was working at
this hotel
downtown phoenix that was like connected
to the uh the comedy club down there
stand up live
yeah yeah oh yeah was that the palomar
hotel yeah i worked at the palomar
and so um um
i was working there and uh bill burr had
came in
he was staying there because he was
doing some shows and uh
i helped him with his luggage or whatnot
like and that was just like it was kind
of
it was all this was just organic it was
all it was all organic
and uh you know i was helping him with
his luggage and then uh
the whole time he was there we were just
we were just chopping it up when he like
first got in
and we were you know i told him i was a
comic but we were we were talking sports
more than anything because uh
he's a celtics guy right and the celtics
were playing uh
the suns and uh we were just chopping up
about sports
and then he was like are you funny and i
was like
yeah and then he was like and i was like
okay
and then he was like well won't you
won't you uh
won't you come by tonight and then let
me have you open for me
and so that right there was like the
moment where i was like
oh [ __ ] and you'd been doing like open
mic stuff prior to this
yeah and i had been i've been opening it
for like like i was getting like local
work at the at the club
opening up for bill burr is a big deal a
massive deal just like
sold out crowd yeah yeah the the that
room
at stand-up live seats like close to 600
it's a great it's a great club too yeah
great club
and i um you know i never done that club
like sold out because i had opened for
people that you know kind of just like
lower level like touring uh comics but
like you know got enough
uh name for themselves to where they
didn't get to make a move around yeah
yeah yeah
and um you know it was it was one of the
most nerve-wracking things
like ever like i went home i couldn't go
to sleep i couldn't take a like a nap or
anything
and then so you went home and couldn't
go to sleep because you did it or
because you knew you were about to do it
yeah when i uh so when i
got off work um and i was going home
because i worked the early shift right
and i was going home like and i usually
like take like a 20 minute nap just to
get my
just get restarted and i couldn't even
sleep i was like man i can usually take
a nap like it's nothing
after work but i couldn't even like
because i just kept thinking about it
and then uh the time came for it you
know
opened up it went really good and then
he let me finish out the whole weekend
with him he was like yeah just
you know yeah finish it out and uh he
even paid me
too which was like wow on top of that
like
yeah i wasn't even expecting any of that
like and he was super nice and i was
like uh
i even asked i was like man what made
you like you know
right give me a shot like that and he's
like what's the worst that was going to
happen you're going to bomb for five
minutes
you know 10 minutes like what so you
know
yeah then he was like he goes you know
and i also had like
you know intuition like i was like oh i
bet he'd be good
do you and bill burke still still
keeping any sort of contact man
yeah so uh uh yeah like i see him around
at the comedy store of course yeah
and uh i've got i've gotten real close
with uh joe rogan
and uh so joe rogan will do like his joe
rogan and friends type shows
and uh i had to follow bill burr
one night which was like insane because
you're going after him bro he's so funny
and he's
he's a monster he's a monster so like
okay so
we're backstage at the store you know in
the main room
and you've been there right yeah of
course yeah yeah yeah of course and um
so we're backstage in the main room
chilling and then uh i didn't even know
bill burr was on the
lineup like joe just says show up and
right and then we get
you know we just get going so bill walks
in and he's like joe you know i want to
go
you know a little early tonight i'm not
feeling too good and i was like
oh is he is he is he going to go before
me or after me
you know to me because i wasn't going i
knew i was going earlier on the lineup
because it was
it was a pretty stacked lineup and uh
you know so i'm sitting there for like
you know 45 minutes before showtime
because we're all just chilling there
talking
and i'm just kind of like when is he
going up you know and then
the sound guy comes back he's like all
right joe how are we doing this
he's like all right it's gonna go uh
derek
burr chappelle lacy tony hits
me and i was like all right you know and
at that moment
which was weird immediately at that
moment
i thought about everything i went
through like in my life
it was like it was like the weirdest
thing that was like my first thought was
like
everything that i've been through like
all the crazy [ __ ]
you know with my family my stepfather
losing my brother i thought about all
that
and then i looked at where i was and
then i was like i could do this
you know i was like i could do this did
you kill it
yeah i actually did and the only way and
like i and like when i was up there like
it was just like going like people were
laughing yeah like you know
but what was funny like because this
could knock you off your [ __ ] socks
you know of course
and uh when when um when they bring bill
up
he got a standing ovation walking out i
mean he's bill burke yeah and they
didn't
they weren't expecting him right you
said no yeah because i i think
uh i've been to a couple of joe rogan
shows and i feel like every time i go
someone just jumps on stage yeah there's
you yeah so like there's some [ __ ]
there's certain cats that are like they
call them drop-ins yep there's only
certain cats
like they kind of got the pass yeah like
chris rock of course chappelle you know
seinfeld
uh martin lawrence right like yeah go
ahead do what you want yeah yeah when
those guys walk in it's like
yeah when do you want to go up oh okay
we'll put you up where's one of them
yeah bro and uh yeah he got a standing
ovation walking out i'm like
damn you know you're getting this like
getting that rush or whatever but
you know needless to say i was just like
hey you know
they already heard bill burr they
haven't heard me yet so
that was when you first moved out here
no that was uh that was just that was
um almost a year ago yeah so
i remember when you first moved out here
and um i remember
now when i moved out here were you like
yeah everybody moves out here no
no no no no no i [ __ ] with you okay i
was like yo
chappelle got it like the thing is is
like you'll just know people like got it
like
like yo like you could just like like
you could do whatever you want
yeah because you're chapelle yeah so if
you wanted to do anything else you could
have did it
i thought you were a cheerleader yeah
true you're right you know what i mean
like i respect that
and so yeah i was like oh yeah yeah
chappelle stand up of course the guy's
[ __ ] was hilarious in school
yeah he's the [ __ ] you know what's so
crazy and he's the black guy with the
punk rock t-shirts like
there's another one in here that's an
angle for an entire stand-up special
i even think that what was the one clip
you did on uh comedy central i saw that
was i was like yeah yeah he's talking
about his life i was there
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i did that like
white friends and uh-huh
yeah growing up in mason and [ __ ] but
yeah it was like uh
i forget when i i think because i listen
to joe rogan
probably if not every episode when he
has some of the crazy kooky right wing
dudes i i'd fall off but yeah
but for the most part i probably listen
to like almost i would say 80
of all his [ __ ] and um
and i remember he brought you up and i
was like
oh [ __ ] it's about to get real for this
kid
dude he's like the king maker yeah and
it was so wild is that
like literally i haven't even been on
this podcast yet
but literally anytime he says my name or
anything like that
i just start like all of a sudden i
start getting a bunch of follows and i'm
like
[ __ ] like what but it's like a lot at
like a time in a wild way and i'm like
the hell and then all of a sudden my
home like some of my homies would be
like yo
i heard it yeah broke is talking about
you right now he said this this and that
so how did you guys become friends bro
that was a random
that was like all all the [ __ ] that
happens to me is so [ __ ] wrong
because
for people who don't realize i mean joe
rogan is the most successful podcaster
ever and
for people who are watching this aren't
tapped in with the stand-up world like
he's like loki the king banger like like
like if you like
if he like co-signs you as a comedian oh
that's
that's a big it's a big plug it's a huge
plug yeah it's like
i said they compare it to like johnny
carson like back in the day yeah like if
you got on johnny carson
yeah and now if you go do joe rogan's
podcast it's like you know
yeah you can at least go on tour oh yeah
yeah you're gonna do good
yeah so you guys became friends how
um so the comedy store has this so they
have like they're paid regulars right
yep and they have this program where
like
you work your way up into a paid regular
call the development spots
and that's that's what that's like the
status i'm at there right now
and um uh i was going to do like one of
my development spots so like
they they put a development spot like
right at the top of the show they just
go up and do like five minutes set blah
blah blah
spot for the uh for the week right and
um
i was doing one uh where rogan was on
the lineup
and um usually like
when i first when i was first doing them
i would just kind of just sit there
quiet you know just
because all the big dogs are back there
and i kind of was just like chilling the
corner you know what i mean
and uh then he came on he just started
talking to me he's like what's up man
i was like oh what's up homie like we
just started uh
chopping it up then we started talking
about like we got real
deep we all of a sudden we started
talking about like you know
he started talking about his dad i
started talking about like my
you know stepfather and the crazy the
crazy [ __ ] we went through with them
we started talking about like you know
our anger problems we got like then we
started talking about books
and all this [ __ ] and it was it was a
really great conversation
and then um uh as i'm leaving because i
just had got off stage you know
i went to go say bye to him i was like
all right joe you know pleasure blah
blah blah
and he was like wait what what's your
instagram man i want to follow you blah
blah blah
i was like oh [ __ ] i was like you know
you know there it is i was already
following him
right but yeah he started following me
and then
you know uh um i remember we had talked
to uh talked about
he geeks out over my cheerleading of
course it's like he thinks it's like the
craziest
thing yeah he's just like a guy your
size you know
flipping doing that throwing people
around yeah he goes it's it's insane
like
and i because i you know a guy my size
isn't supposed to
be able to do the flips that yes like
i'm able to do it's not it's yeah it's
like it shouldn't be a thing it's a lot
of weight to like
carry yeah needless to say and so he's
just like
you know geeked out over that and um you
know
then he gave me his number he's like yo
come come open for me tonight at the
store you know i got a spot for you blah
blah
i was like whoa and i didn't know if he
had like seen me perform yet or anything
like that
but he kind of was just like yeah you
know i'll throw you up
and ever since then we've just been cool
yeah and then like so you're on the the
king and the sting podcast
yeah with brendan schaub and theovan
right
so those two did you just because i feel
like the comedy store is like where
everybody kind of meets up is that how
you met them
as well or you know i met theo in
brandon back in 2016 actually yeah
in arizona and arizona theo wasn't even
like
they weren't even like where they're at
right now oh of course not yeah
yeah 2016 [ __ ] no yeah no not at all
yeah
so like yeah we were just you know uh
just from
you know i would hang out at the the the
comment like the tempi improv were stand
up live
all the time just because like i was
tight with all the staff there and you
know they would just let me come kick it
you know
no no uh no problems and uh
you know and then i would just you know
those dudes would just come up just
start talking to me
because like i said i i don't know what
it is about me
sitting in a corner by myself or
something like that but people just like
hey man what you up to you know type
type deal like which is what happens a
lot
and then uh sometimes it's usually
through like a mutual friend but
you know yeah i met both of them you
know 2016 and all of a sudden like
did you guys like stay in contact that
whole time yeah or like oh that's
definitely yeah because they were like
yo man take my number down like
you know real cool [ __ ] like that blah
blah like
it's funny because i feel like brendan
shop is the kind of guy you wouldn't
hang out with in high school oh hell no
hell no we say that we say that [ __ ] all
the time like bro you guys would
yo you just roasted him the other day
when he was talking about nickelback
oh you remember that yeah i was like yo
yo this guy's shop is not a music head
whatsoever
and you're like you're like yeah you
would [ __ ] listen to nickels yeah i
was like yes you would
make makes sense and he's he's so yeah
and he tries to make fun of me about
like you know he probably loves drake
too
yeah he does he does yeah he does
because he uh
he got a picture with drake of course
and he was like
i was like uh i was like what's he like
he was like man i was so excited but
anyways yeah so he
like you know i like punk but he thinks
like
metallica's punk rock no he he thinks
that like he's a
he thinks i'm a big green day fan and
i'm like that's not
yeah that sounds i was like that's not
what i listen to but he doesn't know
that
right right he's like that he's like
that that jock in high school that
like make fun of you they were like oh
well your mom and you're like
oh okay cool yeah you're funny bro yeah
he's like
it's like bro because i think he i
follow i watch the podcast i thought
yeah i watched the
the one with him and brian cowan yeah
and uh yeah no he's definitely that guy
though yeah it's and it's hilarious but
he
like literally hands down is one of the
nicest people
yeah i'm a fan generous like bro like
you know during the quarantine i was
like i ain't had no gym membership
right right he bought me like these
expensive ass jump ropes which i didn't
know jump ropes could get expensive
right like i'll just go get some from
marshalls
yeah but he brought me like these
weighted ones they got a
app you got to download with it yeah and
then uh he got he gave me a kettlebell
all this [ __ ]
anytime i need fitness [ __ ] i would just
go to the middle of ross or marshalls
you know i got that little area
oh yeah that ran reloading electronics
and weights is there marshalls out here
yeah at least in burbank there's one
yeah oh i didn't see it in hollywood
so he bought you some some stuff yeah
like he's just cool like that he'll you
know he'll take me on the road with him
too
and then like you know them bringing me
on the
as a you know permanent uh person on the
king and the sting
has been like you know like i don't know
like all of a sudden
my following and all this [ __ ] people
just like [ __ ] with me heavy and like i
didn't realize
like what's so funny is i used to get
made fun of a lot about like the music i
would listen to
like being the black kid that listens to
it and literally
now like so many like a lot of the dm's
i get
is people asking me about music or want
to talk music with me
it's like insane like so many people
follow me because they see all the band
t-shirts i wear
yeah on the uh on the podcast and like
that's just
that's just me being me but like you
know hey girl random tangent
who's worse nickelback or creed
i'll nickelback really yeah i'll go with
creole on that one
you take creed over nickelback yeah i
feel like i always say that
that's the music that white women dance
to at white strip clubs in the middle of
america oh yeah they do
with all butt open working a pole to
that working a pole
what the [ __ ] is going on getting down
with the get down
crazy no so yeah like to give anybody
like like kind of give people
some background because for the people
who don't understand how there's this
black dude who cheerleaded
and [ __ ] loves punk rock music how
did you grow up
because your brother was kind of a
gangster low-key at school yeah
your brother was like he was like like
yeah he was a goonie
on the floor my brother and i were like
when it came to like that stuff
polar opposite right like how did you
get into all that like
you know obviously that was before the
internet right now i feel like people
can get into any kind of music they want
because it's so much easier
yeah oh back in the day it wasn't even
like that dude i like
literally i gotta i get i got into all
that stuff uh
you know because my mom she loves music
and like our home was so hectic and [ __ ]
you know because of my stepfather crazy
uh
we we like she like that was the time i
saw her at her happiest was when she was
listening to music
and she was playing like you know during
that time like my earliest memories is
like
you know bobby brown and like you know
uh
[ __ ] brian mcknight like all the
h-town like
jodeci like she was really into like a
lot of that
uh stuff and she was always you know
whenever she was like cleaning up or
anything like that was what she she got
down with
and um so i started getting into it and
then
you know um obviously growing up like in
arizona
you know more i feel like more like
obviously
west coast hip-hop was touching arizona
um so like uh you know snoop's first
album was like
one of my favorites down man i just i
just told this guy
it just i think he just had an
anniversary for him that's one of my
favorite albums ever yeah
great album and uh better than
reasonable doubt by hair
whoa you say that in public my hair
don't get stuck of course okay i just
know jay-z friends get crazy
but uh i'm a jay-z fan i know yeah yeah
but uh yeah and then i just you know
switched the radio station
i heard some rock and i was like damn
this is tight too
the edge uh yeah oh [ __ ]
there's the only station playing punk
rock back there oh man that's so crazy
yeah the edge one yeah 103.9
yeah so um
yeah cause you were like into some like
real hardcore [ __ ] though yeah then i
got into like all that like
the stuff that wasn't on the radio
because none of that shit's on the radio
yeah cause when i when i take a dive in
music
oh i take a deep dive and i go like as
far
as i like i can like i don't i need to
know it all
right right right like that's just how i
am that's because like
i'm a big henry rollins geek he's like
that you know
now cheerleading that started in high
school or did that start in middle
school no i started high school
so i started at westwood yeah and so
like what
what was the was it to get [ __ ] was it
yeah i did it because i like the girl
yeah like i'm gonna hang out with these
yeah
but i didn't get her oh you did it first
a particular girl yeah
which girl you know her you might have
know her who marissa lopez
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah because i
i played in a band with her brother we
were trying to do like a
sky band right and didn't even succeed
but
uh that ended up breaking up but i still
jammed that with him man
what the hell was that name we didn't
even play shows this was before westwood
though uh oh before westwood okay yeah
damn yeah [ __ ] drew my mind but
anyways uh so
i i still jammed out with him right you
know because i you know you're trying to
smash your sister
i i don't know if i was trying to bro i
would love her you were trying to like
take her on a date sure
yeah out like applebee's two for
like i wasn't trying to like smash it
right you were trying to take a real
expression i wanted to fall in love
yeah yeah bro i was writing
like i was writing poems like i was
writing
damn like i went i went in dude
you know so that's how you got into
cheerleading yeah that's crazy and then
you ended up but i already knew how to
do flips and [ __ ] i taught myself that
when i was like
i mean i think it was like five when i
was taught myself how to do this [ __ ]
yeah westwood high school games the hot
pocket remember the hot pocket what was
that
the uh the area where everybody was just
crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah there was like the professional
like fans
mm-hmm we'd be like why don't you just
play football yeah exactly it's like you
don't trust that guy my boy like dudley
hunter
shout out to dudley but i remember he
used to just paint himself every game
and like like bro you're in shape like
go play football
[ __ ] in shape being an orange
guy every [ __ ] saturday what's wrong
with you
yeah that shit's crazy like now with
obviously with stand-up man like the
natural progression is to start
acting well now it's also podcast which
you have your own podcast right yeah
yeah something you said earlier that i
thought like
that is very accurate um as far as
comedy goes
it's very comparable to hip-hop like as
far as like the
you know everybody wants to say they
yeah yeah they do that yeah
yeah rap and everybody wants to say yeah
i'm a comic like
because you you'll get cats that'll go
up and you're like oh you're just doing
this because
you want to say that you're a comic
you're not even like
trying to do anything with it which like
honestly this pandemic has
i think it's cleared a lot of those
fools out they got to move back home
yeah yeah because they probably realize
their worth they're like oh
i need to reevaluate myself because i
need to make an actual living
yes you know what i mean like if it's
not your dream or it's not something
you're going for then like
so you're going for it all yeah man so
like because i could see you totally
acting i would love to oh bro
yeah you're gonna be in movies bro i
know that's what they said it's gonna be
great
even more so than a lot of those guys
that are in that little circle like
you know you're young you're got a
unique look like
you'll be literally those cats like you
know that whole squad they just do
podcasts they don't do oh they do the
[ __ ] out of pockets yeah they do the
[ __ ] out of podcasts they don't do any
acting or anything
but i but i like i don't know i like
performing i like entertainment itself i
like it's i don't know it's just one
obvious you're gonna be in a judd apatow
movie i can feel it man i'll do that
what's up judd
what's the other one what's the other
guy there's judd and then there's
um there's another big comedy guy i
don't know that does that uh
also uh that directs comedy movies will
ferrell's the jed apatow guy right
well i think will does a lot with judd
avatar and then the other guy is the guy
who does like
40 year old virgin and i don't know that
was john
oh seth rogen says rogan does a lot you
know seth rogen doesn't
maybe maybe they're the same guy i think
a lot of it's judd apatow
yeah shout out to him yeah bro he does a
lot he just did um
pete davidson's uh uh yeah king of
staten island yeah i saw that it was
interesting
it was it wasn't it wasn't a bad movie
oh i liked it i thought it was good
i thought it was it was i just thought
it was kind of like
it wasn't very funny how about that
there were some funny parts in it oh
like he uh the fact he had to take the
like bill burst kids the school was like
oh yeah that was pretty funny i'm like
yo who the [ __ ] is letting their
[ __ ] kid walk to school with some
random ass
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going
there a guy that's trying to get with
that person's mom what the [ __ ]
that's right he did yeah yeah no i think
that like
with the stand-up thing like i think
it's it's also like
because of the podcasting [ __ ] it's more
on uh
like it's easier to to i feel like you
know five years ago
like if you were like a stand-up guy you
had to be like you had to be like a real
geek
yeah you know now it's like you don't
have to be like my you know there's
just normal people who just like joe
rogan in their life and then they they
find these other podcasts and then
people who never i think the comedy
store has become this
is always been legendary but i feel like
there's been like a resurgence
oh yeah definitely they all talk about
like how there was a point in time
where it was just like no one went there
yeah because i remember even it happened
with the um
like it took a downfall like honestly
when like
i think when like the mencia rogan thing
happened because if they broke because
they because rogan got banned it was
like a toss-up between the comedy store
and the laugh factory
when i first moved out here and then i
was like oh no there's a difference
you ever been to chocolate sundaes at
the lab factory i haven't
fired that's one of the most fire shows
let me ask you this gary owen is a white
guy
bro he does black who does black comedy
uh-huh right uh-huh
so like when you go to a gary owen show
he could do chocolate sundaes he could
do all that [ __ ] right yes
you're a black guy
[Laughter]
who doesn't necessarily do quote unquote
black comedy yeah i just talk about me
you just talk about you and your
experience right but like
when have you done like a black comedy
night yeah and do they [ __ ] with you
yeah the first time i did it
man i bombed so hard
i bombed so hard because i can only
imagine like it's just it's just
different it's like it is
gary owens not gonna go and like pull up
and and and do a show with
jim gaffigan you know first of all gary
owen has the blackest audience
then like something like and he's
[ __ ] hilarious and he's [ __ ]
hilarious but yeah you're right like
yeah yeah
some of the like like he probably has
out of like most of them
he does yeah that's what i'm saying he
has a his audience is
black you're not gonna see like a white
person in there or any other
like it's black i've been to a couple
gary owen shows oh okay nevermind
okay well you see bootleg there but no
um yeah
the first time i did like an all-black
room um yeah i bombed hard as [ __ ]
i was doing a weekend and the cl the
club runner back home in
arizona uh for the clubs i was doing
this through casey courier
um he was like you know he was like
building me up
and he goes i've seen what you can do in
this room
what can you do in this room and i went
up there and i was like man let's do
this
bruh i [ __ ] tanked they did like i
i didn't get i got i got three laughs at
the start
the middle and the end other than that
it bro it was the longest 12 minutes of
my life
and i was waiting for the light and then
so then um
then the the headliner that i was open
for was
uh rodney perry okay shout out to ronnie
perry um
he was like hey man he goes i'm glad you
stayed you
he goes that's good but you're not
clearing something up
immediately up top he was like you gotta
you gotta address that you can't just
like start telling jokes he goes
because the thing about black people you
know doing like performing for black
people he goes
they got questions about you as soon as
you walk on stage
and he goes and he was like you
completely missed that you got to say
those things clear it up off the rip
he's like you got to clear it up and he
goes and then you can say whatever you
want after that because
they already know you he goes but they
don't know you right now and they got
questions they're looking at you like
who's this [ __ ] yeah they're
like something different about him yeah
they know it they think he goes they get
sent he goes so you go as soon as you
grab the microphone they know
as soon as you grab the microphone you
don't even have to talk yet they just
know
he goes you got to say it he goes so
do all that like up top and then i
remember i went home
and i changed up like my whole set and
then
bro when i tell you i did it i
[ __ ] did it knocked out oh man yeah
it was it was like
one of like the like greatest moments
in my comedy career because it was like
[ __ ] yeah like i saw them meant
and then they had this uh um show at the
store
um uh talking what the hell's it called
it's on thursday nights
damn it they're gonna punch me in the
face for uh
not knowing this one but but it's all
all black uh
room and uh sometimes i would get my
development spots on that room
and i already knew like boom boom boom
and like they
they uh the lady that runs it um
michelle she she [ __ ] uh
loves me and always gave me like more
time and stuff like that because usually
comics
bomb that room you know what i mean like
because a lot of it's like you know i
mean yeah dude
black people but black people are the
best people the best audience to ever
perform for
i can imagine because here's the thing
they ain't gonna write a blog
about your joke they're not gonna try to
cancel you they're gonna try to cancel
you
bro if you ain't funny they're just
gonna say it on site not on twitter not
on twitter they're going to tell you
right there
yeah that's people don't think about it
again yeah white people will be like oh
my god
one of the coolest moments i know right
jesus gary gray was in the crowd running
i had him dying i was like
yes that's fire yeah yeah it's crazy man
this cancel coaching [ __ ] is wild bro
oh bro it's it's you know i you know
i i think about it a lot you know
because
because i try to i just try to
understand so much because i want to
understand
a lot of perspectives i want to i want
to try to like understand and
if you know a lot of times yeah i i
don't click with it and i think
the reason why i don't click with it
because like i think
my stepfather was abusive he was abusive
as [ __ ] you know what i mean
and but i don't want to go after him
you know i don't want to go like because
like i think about like
when i went like i went through i had to
go i have
i've had three different anger
management uh
teachers and oh [ __ ] you got some real
anger
yeah yeah it's right i went to anger
management for about eight weeks
because i i got yeah i uh i punched a
window
oh damn and uh and then i had to go i
went to court and then they put me
i had to go to anger management off
country club and university
oh see mine was through like the uh i
remember where that task is where
everybody would have to go piss
yeah that's where i had to go um i had
to go through the schools i went to
okay they sent me so what were you
saying so you were sorry back to what
you were saying oh but yeah like
okay so my anger management teacher
they didn't teach me to go after people
they taught me to go after myself
so like that's why i don't connect with
trying to cancel someone
like that like i don't want to like you
know i don't blame my biological father
for not being around those years
like i don't blame my mom for like when
she stayed with my
stepdad step dad because it's like i
don't know
that i'd rather i'd rather you know
i don't know i'd rather make my life
cool on my own than like
right because then you're relying on
other people's choices for your
happiness yeah
like that's not gonna be like like yeah
save my stepfather you know
like yeah i i want you giving people a
lot of power yeah
yeah exactly like say yeah i went after
him you know he ends up going to prison
for the [ __ ] blah blah how does that
make you better ten years after that
dude
it does it like it literally does
nothing for me like i didn't do
i didn't do anything for me i did it
because i was i don't like him
but it's like why so right you know that
like
like i said i try to understand
everything you know i try to be
completely honest with you everything
about me i think that there's a lot of
stuff where it's like okay man
there's definitely people who do [ __ ]
yeah well you're like okay well you're a
piece of [ __ ]
and i mean you get aired out all day
like i
there's you know there's a lot of that
you know that i'm like yeah i agree with
but then there's just certain [ __ ] where
it's like
like wait wait like you can't never make
a mistake
yeah like that like i was like the one i
think about like a lot is like that
kevin hart situation like
crazy like he had old insensitive tweets
but like back then like
dude if like you know and obviously
nobody likes to
s slur gay people love gay people mm-hmm
like eminem couldn't put albums out
anymore oh
yeah if like we went back and like held
people to the same standards we hold
them today well it's just like well
the thing is like how come no one looked
post that tweet like like like after
that tweet like
why didn't anyone like look at his life
and the way he is after that right like
oh yeah like why did they why did they
define him off
that's something because if you if you
looked at it you go oh he hasn't done
that was the last time he did something
like that yeah wait you're right the
person could have
the person what the person could have
done has been like
oh man kevin hart used to talk like this
and he doesn't anymore
man he's moving like he grew he grew
that's so awesome that people can grow
people can change
but man we like you know i think a lot
of people are just
because they can't go after someone else
that they i think that is a little bit
more
closer to them so they try to i think
they just go after these people and try
to make this like
thing me i'm i'm unapologetic as [ __ ]
like
me too i mean like i don't like
i don't have a fear of like not being
liked
or not being you know people yeah i
think too what's great about like
being in your position is like you have
your own platform you're also a comedian
so it's like
you're so i i want my comedians to say
offensive things
yeah well cause like like yo think about
the chappelle special that came out
over this trans bit and how it was it
was really funny
like it's not coming from a place of
hatred but he's a he's a comedian
and he's supposed to make fun of people
yeah that's all people that's the thing
about comedy
the reason why it's funny because we're
saying [ __ ] differently
we're gonna say it in a way that not
everybody is thinking yeah so we're
always thinking of it in a different way
and and every time a comedian writes a
joke
no comedian is writing a joke to go man
i want to [ __ ] bash on these people
no comedian does that yeah they're just
trying to they're writing to joke
because damn that's funny
the intent is funny and then there
what's the one guy
uh what's his name the guy who made the
[ __ ] up kobe
joke on twitter when he died oh ari
shafir yeah now that guy that guy's
not just not funny like hey bro like
what what were you thinking
but does but do i think he deserves to
get cancelled no like he lost
it was a yeah it was a horrible joke
horrible joke horrible joke and even if
it wasn't a joke
like he's just like he didn't even he
didn't he didn't even have to do that
read the room buddy
yeah read the rules read the [ __ ]
rules sometimes you just gotta read the
room
yeah yeah yeah but you but i agree with
you like like i don't [ __ ] with that
dude because of what he said
because i'm like yo he's probably not
that great of a guy plus i
plea [ __ ] poisoned the bert guy with
some drugs overt crisis
yeah which was like bro what kind of guy
does that what the [ __ ]
gave him ecstasy or something without
him yeah something like that something
all right well look
i'm just not gonna i don't have to
support the guy but he should be able to
still go
get booked but and like here's the thing
like people don't realize about
comedians like you got to think of
comedians as like uh
like like uh like tv you got a lot of
channels yeah
like you ain't gonna i don't like uh i
don't like you know
i'm not a big friends guy exactly
i i thought two and a half men was trash
but guess what
people like it that's how you get that's
how you got to think of comedy so like i
don't have like
like i don't like get weird like like
i've had like one lady
um you know come up to me after a show
because she was offended by a joke
and i was just like okay you're at a co
you should you should be offended like
people she she wanted a battle and i was
just like okay
there's no point to put any energy there
yeah because one i knew i
like i know my intentions yeah i know
where i'm coming from
i know who i am yeah and i know what i'm
saying and first of all you can't pick
and choose
throughout my set of what you thought
was uh
offensive or not there'd be no time to
live if people
did that with everything in their life
oh bro and there's people who do that
yeah they do that you know what they're
going to do i'll tell you what because i
i used to be like my anger i used to
just pop you know what i mean
it was just a lot of it just because i
was sensitive to like you know i thought
everybody needed to like
you know to my needs but you know you
get exhausted
yeah after what because because it
doesn't truly because i used to be the
same way where i would like
i would like argue with people on
facebook which is the worst [ __ ]
oh bro you're one of those people i
would i would see some [ __ ] or somebody
would try to say some slick
[ __ ] some local rapper or something and
i would just
oh why am i giving energy to this [ __ ]
because
because i know it's so funny because
like
no conversation is authentic over the
internet
never think about it like you didn't you
didn't hit me up to do this podcast
to go hey we're gonna we're gonna do it
over twitter though right
you know what i mean that doesn't
doesn't make any sense
so it's like you know when people like
go back and
like i don't know you if someone if
someone tells me
hey this happened and then i go how do
you know
like how you know that's true and then
they go we'll go look at twitter
i'll slap him in the face because i hate
that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah no it's crazy just as it's just
also people just get their information
from these places like
that yeah and they hang their hat on it
i have like
my mom will send me [ __ ] she sees on
facebook i'll be like mom
i'm like mom get the [ __ ] off facebook
sure mom almost like literally be like
yo i don't i don't know if the
coronavirus is real kevin
i'm like mom stop going on facebook
stay away you know exactly where she was
at yeah like yo you you're like oh
you're on facebook yeah you saw it on
facebook
mom stay the [ __ ] off of facebook yeah
like
but most old people get [ __ ] off of
facebook yeah 100
it's like they're [ __ ] it's like
their news source no matter what side of
the spectrum you're on politically
hey old people ruin facebook i'll tell
you that but facebook is
[ __ ] up it's the worst that i've
always said
deactivated or whatever and then it's
because it's also people who you like
actually know in real life and you're
like [ __ ] this guy is a real piece of
[ __ ]
damn i knew this guy let me unfollow
like
like i know this guy in real life
twitter's like people you're never gonna
meet twitter's a joke
yeah 100 percent like okay you're you're
you're fam where you at
yeah exactly people are real brave on
twitter real brave
um you you were cool with crystalia
right
i've heard him talk about you yeah
what's going on with this guy man
you know i don't have that information
have you spoken with him since this [ __ ]
popped off man
because listen i don't know what
happened
but either way the guy just the guy did
just have a baby
yeah you know he's got a he's got a girl
and a baby and you know
if if this is the
the the version of what happened is the
version
where he didn't do any of this stuff
then [ __ ] i you got to feel i mean
[ __ ] that sucks man yeah that's what i'm
saying like
it's it's a weird thing you know like
that's why like
i'm not one of those people that like i
don't jump into a group
thing i don't i don't think correctly i
don't
i can't think in a group format i have
to step away
from [ __ ] to like understand it from
like myself and then i go
well what what what is this information
right what can i do with this
information
and then it's like oh you know then you
kind of like
you know dwindle it down you know um
uh yeah as far as that goes you know
yeah like like that's why i had to get
away from the social media world because
like
like like well like as far as twitter
and like facebook because when you when
you go on it you just see like
the [ __ ] and this is supposed to be
correct and i'm like bro i read books
like why the [ __ ]
am i like looking at this [ __ ] for you
know something correct
and um you know um
i was just like listen you know i've
never known him
to do any of that yeah do any of that
you haven't had any
communication with him since everything
popped off yeah i reached out to him
yeah i did you know and and and i and i
you know it was weird because i i hate
the fact that like
i was letting social media like define
that if i should or not
right right you know where it's like you
know and i had i had a long time i
had a long talk with my my girl about it
you know
and she was like he's the first dude you
meant comedy you know like
he you know so he was the first guy you
met in comedy
the first guy i met in comedy what year
was that that was uh
2011. oh wow yeah you met crystal lee in
2011
he wasn't even like anything this is
before he was that justin bieber's
favorite comment yeah yeah
yeah this is before before that and so
this is a guy who like
did he help did he kind of serve as a
mentor at all to you like in a comedy
show
uh yeah he yeah he helped me out with
some stuff man he uh you know he's
letting me open for him
you know which is like you know he has
some like the craziest fans
craziest fans in like dopest audience
you know
and um um yeah man
yeah so i've reached out to him and you
know my girl was like you shouldn't feel
guilty about that
yeah yeah i mean you know you know women
like you kind of you should i mean look
you're his friend you should give him
the benefit of the doubt
yeah exactly and and there's and there's
nothing she's like there's nothing wrong
with that
you know like you're you're not you're
not a judge you're not a you know
that's that that's not your lane um but
i was just like you know i reached out
to him
i i said i'm probably the you know
on the lowest lowest part of the totem
pole of people you want to hear from
right now but
you know i just send positivity your way
man
so did you get tested for the
coronavirus
coronavirus i ended up getting it i know
i saw that bro yeah i i got two negative
tests back so i'm good now
but i did get it i went out to arizona
and [ __ ] off in scottsdale and my
roommate had got it
yeah it's [ __ ] up i think she got it
when she went she's she's from arizona
as well right yeah arizona is a goddamn
breeding ground
so weird what was your symptoms
i couldn't smell you oh you couldn't
smell yeah i had i i just had like
your clothes no i could taste my wife
couldn't taste
but she could smell no she couldn't do
either damn
yeah that was that was my roommate she
couldn't she couldn't uh taste it you
didn't catch it
you so you were right because you were
in brandon brandon shop a lot yeah
yeah yeah so i didn't catch it
and another one of my homies had got it
that i was exposed around here i got it
didn't get it my roommate um
it was around her obviously my roommate
yeah didn't get it and then uh
yeah it was shot yeah didn't get it it's
yeah
have you let me ask you this black
people don't get it i'm just kidding no
because
my boy beat out skills got it he's i
mean it's [ __ ] i just kidding
anyway um yeah it was just so crazy
because i would always like watch
brenden shop talk about the mass thing
bro
i i even told her i was like talking
about this you were talking that
[ __ ] i called it i was like bro hey
you thought i'm gonna see it dawg
slapped you upside the head boy
jesus and then he was like he was like i
mean
he goes here's the thing yeah i'm fine
you know he's i'm good
i knew what i was signing up for but he
was like you know it's not worth it he
goes because you know
uh you know he goes i had to record you
know my podcast out of home
like i got to step away from your family
yeah he had like he had to stay in the
bait in his basement yeah
in his basement i mean i understand that
the the idea of like you know what [ __ ]
it
i'm gonna do it because if i get it i'm
gonna get it but i'm gonna still live my
life i don't think that's smart it's a
little selfish but like i get it like
but yeah even like i feel like rogan
kind of
chilled out on his like because he was
on that wave too a little bit
well probably because he probably
because i would say maybe because he
knew more people that were getting it
yeah but like yeah even like i saw him
he was saying like you know he did
houston
yeah he was like dude what it wasn't
worth it it was not worth it he's like i
thought i'd go out like it's just not
worth it like i get it like you did um
the phoenix shows that brandon shop and
brian yeah i didn't get it there stand
up live right uh-huh and that
we that weekend we did those shows is
when
az spiked yeah but the weight so the way
uh
stand up live had did it so like i said
that club seats around like
close to 600. well they only they they
only
let 300 in but they use the you they use
the whole room
so like everybody so like if you if you
were if you
like only people that were sitting by
each other came with each other
came with each other so like otherwise
like and it was like it was spread out
like that
but the way they had the lights it
didn't like we couldn't tell on the
stage
like that it looked like that you know
because it was like the crowd was like
you know
like not lit so uh we we couldn't tell
but
it it seemed like a full room but it's
just everybody was at a distance
uh have you has have you i mean i think
it's inevitable you're gonna end up
going on the joe rogan podcast but has
that
that ever been tossed around officially
oh yeah we've talked about it
yeah it'll happen when it happens it and
then it's over
you know and then it's a wrap and i'm
like i'm just kidding
i'm like what's a westwood what's the
west
i am not from mesa what i'm from beverly
hills
beverly i'm from west hollywood i'm from
west hollywood that's your wheat grass
pour on the wheatgrass yeah i go to
creation every morning
yeah shout outs i did a juice cleanse
that [ __ ] sucks you did that
five days how did you feel you didn't
feel like you were hungry
uh yeah like like yeah i did oh you
didn't like by the time
i say about like i thought they said it
doesn't matter by the second or third
day i was like used to it so it was cool
but those first like 48 hours but i also
didn't
everyone's like me feel so good i didn't
i was like man this
i'm [ __ ] like a crazy person like
this like i'm good
you know [ __ ] i mean shout out to
creation but yeah [ __ ] the juice cleanse
i'm straight
oh [ __ ] that um yo who okay i know
you're a big oasis fan
big oasis fan you can have dinner with
either henry rollins is it noah
gallagher is did i get his name and [ __ ]
no no gallagher who would it be
you know i've i've performed with henry
and like had a good conversation with so
you've already talked to him so it's
so it's noel gallagher that's fair yeah
they're such polar opposites musically
oh very well
that's the funny thing about it we were
like how are you know
i'm like it's well okay what people
don't realize
about oasis is that
oasis has a very punk attitude right
and that's why like that's what caught
my attention with him
and like outside of wonderwall and
champagne supernova most people don't
realize
they have like some kind of like harder
harder [ __ ]
harder yeah because when i was a kid i
had this the album what's the story
morning yeah yeah great album
yeah great album yeah you had that album
of course look at you
yeah that [ __ ] my i mean when i grew up
my cousin who was in and out of prison
put me on the that [ __ ] like suicidal
tendencies
okay yeah all that kind of [ __ ] but yeah
oasis was one of those bands
wow yeah that's pretty dope white cd
right yeah cd's white yeah
yeah i got my cd book yeah damn
of course hey what's the one band what's
what like it's funny because i always
there's certain music i hear when i when
when whenever it pops up
in my life i'll be like yo this is this
is westwood
what's like that like like a a band that
like
you think like this was like the band in
high school oh the bandit oh
it's for me it's always authority zero
oh bruh
damn or bionic jive
it was wow doug cooper gave me that cd
damn
uh or the there was also the funk
junkies the funk junkies nah but the
funk junkies were never popping like
they weren't popping the kids in high
school were bumping authority zero yeah
they were bumping authority zero
but i you know i i listen to authority
zero but that wasn't like mine
that wasn't your bag yeah your yeah i'd
say probably black flag
that was my like like any time it comes
on like i know exactly
where i was where i was my how i was
you know my whole existence yeah man
that's
that's crazy it is so did you start to
get into that hardcore [ __ ] in high
school or before that
you said because you said you were in a
band before that right yeah i started uh
i got
i got in the hardcore stuff uh in junior
high pow patriots baby yeah when i was
like 13.
yo we grew up around a lot of mormons a
lot
lots of mormon lots of them and i think
that trump being president has shown me
that there are much worse conservative
people in the world than mormons
because yo when i wait when i i move
forward warmers are tight
they're tight because listen let me tell
you something when i moved from
sunny slope to mesa i was like thursday
i was like 13. am i using sunny yeah
oh bro so i grew up my cousin
who went to post in mountain view yeah
he scared me about mormon people
oh he was like yo they got cameras in
every house in mesa
he just made up all this wild [ __ ] i was
like damn man the mormons are the ops
bro yeah [ __ ] and then i ended up going
to school with them
and like a lot of the homies in school
were all mormon they were like the
nicest
that's what i'm saying like westwood
carried a lot of mormon yeah and they
were super nice
like like a good amount of the white
kids that went to westwood were mormons
probably mormon yeah yeah and they were
cool cool as [ __ ]
yeah i think mormons are tight bro i got
a lot of water i mean yeah we got a lot
of water and then i just remember being
in high school like you know you like
grow up in mesa
there's like a big ass mormon temple on
main street right up on main street
and like i would just always like i'd be
like nah there's no way they think that
this is real and then i just researched
it i'm like oh
[ __ ] they think it's real dang
and then you would like have your
warming homies who were kind of woke
you'd be like hey hey you really don't
like the underwear thing like
i've seen you drink soda before bro
[Laughter]
like come on that underwear thing is
real though bro they roll like that
crazy it's it's it's if you actually
cool
no they're super cool but god damn i
don't know if i can roll with that
underwear well they also weren't [ __ ]
with black people until like 1970s yeah
they weren't wrong with black people
i think in the book of mormon black
people are called nephites
that's tight and
yeah and they weren't allowed in the
church yeah
he fights something like that you you
might want to look that up
knees fight i like that yeah shout out
to the mormons though choose the right
choose the right uh ct they got the ccr
rings
and uh shout out to [ __ ] uh uh temple
lights
steve young's a mormon yeah i mean shout
out to the 49ers
steve young's mormons yeah he went to
byu oh [ __ ] i didn't know that
you know what's crazy is a lot of the
mormon kids in school though you could
tell that they're like grew up in like
these super weird conservatives because
it'd be like the kids who would like go
to like and do heroin and or like
sniff people bro like that's what i'm
saying like
mormons like or the mormon like there
was like those like two or three mormon
chicks that were like
blowing dudes at parties bro because
they were i knew some that were either
like
to the [ __ ] or just like just like oh
you're mormon damn i've seen you do some
[ __ ] and yeah and then other ones that
are just like
is there just like an era in our school
where do you remember when kids were
going to rocky point and getting somas
and everything yes
everybody at westwood was so much
[ __ ] on somas
dude so like i was having a conversation
with someone the other day they didn't
know what somas were
i'm like oh
bro i remember i used to i went to eve
it
and there was this kid named rusty creed
do you remember
redhead yeah the red-headed kid man and
i used to ride from sometimes i'd ride
from eva back to westwood with him
because we both went to evit
and this whole used to sniff so much
somas
really like a crazy person i was like
dog
i never got into drugs in my life i mean
i've only smoked weed
i've never even taken a pain pill damn
oh damn really yeah i don't [ __ ] with it
because my whole family's uh you know i
i grew up around a bunch of drug addicts
yeah and i'm out so you're like we just
chill yeah weed
alcohol why do people make weeds such a
big deal
i don't think it is anymore oh it's not
oh okay like a big deal how like
i know i'm sitting here like why do they
make weed such a big deal yeah i mean
i'm still out of there well you're in
l.a now you just go to a store
i almost feel like if you don't smoke
weed now it's almost weird like wait you
don't
like ever like nah never once like wait
what
bro you know you know what would get me
and they said they changed them up
uh edibles edibles would knock
knock like i would puke every time but
they said but i heard they changed up
the
limited i had i had gone to
[Music]
the worst night in my life i ate a whole
cake pop and i was only supposed to see
a quarter of it
i went to a yellow wolf concert at uh
club red
what year was that 2014 yep yeah
yellow wolf and ritz and i went to that
show
and i was sitting on the tour bus in the
back and i was like man i don't even
feel this [ __ ] i'm good
went inside to watch my homie ritz
perform and all of a sudden
i couldn't move bruh have you ever had
the experience where you're so high on
an edible
in a crowded room and you can hear every
conversation if you wanted to like
i could hone into somebody in the middle
of a concert and hear their entire
conversation on the other side of the
venue and i'd be like
what the [ __ ] i he dude
couldn't move my legs no bruh i feel you
and i'm like leaning on my boy like fam
i can't walk
he's like what you mean you're standing
i'm like no but i can't move my leg
i can't move my legs and then i start
you
i started to hallucinate low-key yeah
bro that
like yeah dude i saw garfield the cat
on stage with um slot machine eyeballs
did you yeah but you really do see some
[ __ ] especially if you close your eyes
edible like all of a sudden like my
world is like i just like i could hone
in on people's conversations it was like
i had a super power like a like a ear
like a hearing superpower
and then all the crazy [ __ ] that could
happen to somebody while they're
in that state of mind happened that
night in front of my face
because you know you'll go to like a a
concert in in arizona and there's like
those wild-ass native dudes
oh bruh they go hard in the paint so
this guy
[ __ ] up a security guard right in front
of me
i'm like sitting on the side of the
stage with the old club red and i'm on
the one that was on on the one-on-one
university in the one win yeah yeah
and i'm on the couch and this guy
they're just fighting in front of me and
i didn't think it was real
dude and then i was like i went outside
and sat down and the guy was outside he
was a native dude and then i started
talking to him and i said some
wild ill [ __ ] to him probably yeah and
he wanted to beat me up but i didn't
think he was real
and my i thought it bro i couldn't
believe like what was going on i was
like this is really happening right now
or am i
is it the drugs like it's both but yes
it's really happening
shout out to the natives man hey the
natives go hard to paint
yo that's the one well they're at every
concert rap all of it
metal uh that was never there yeah that
was the one thing like
going to rock shows because i would like
love to get into mosh pits and [ __ ]
and crowdsurf yeah when i was in like
high school and junior high
but like the one thing i would do is
when a skinhead jumped in
or a big native dude jumped in the pit i
had to get out
because that [ __ ] is out for
blood they all they are they see my
little white ass like yo i'm taking it
off yeah they're
they're going for it man but yeah you're
right like natives got they're such
music heads such music heads yeah you'll
see them all kinds of shows man yeah 100
cents definitely tech nine shows yeah a
lot of yeah
when did i see wu tang i think it was
like oh eight
at the marquee oh yeah so routine yeah
yeah they were all up there i got in a
fight with one add a shove homie
shout out to tang yeah what's the best
non rock concert you've been to
ah [ __ ] damn that's a that's a tough one
um
gosh okay um i saw
kendrick before he even was anything
right uh i think he just had made
freshmen
so was it the celebrity theater the bt
no i saw him at a
clubhouse up on broadway yep yep that
[ __ ] got shot up the night the nipsy
show happened
yes the night that yeah um i saw that
show
and there's something i saw on stage in
kendrick
because it was my first time knowing
about him right
and i was like damn this dude is like
the deal
like it was just something about his
energy on stage and the way he
went off that was just so like and he
had he had school boy with him
half soul and all that stuff like uh
that show was dope
snoop dogg in the east siders was
[ __ ]
that was like snoop is like one of those
guys is just like
you don't got to do much on stage you
snoop man bruh and he's gonna
he's gonna play the [ __ ] songs you're
like [ __ ] he could yeah all day
um kanye west touched the sky tour
um 2005. i would say at the
dodge it was when it was dodge theater
yeah i went to that one
that one was fire um
i saw jay-z at uh i think that was the
last rap concert i went to jay-z
out here um no it was in uh [ __ ] was the
arena back home
where the sun's play yeah talking stick
talking stick yeah i saw
uh jay-z that concert was fire as [ __ ]
yeah the kanye thing i saw kanye uh at
marquis
oh that was like way back yeah actually
what was so funny is i think i talked to
you about that
probably yeah you know you were like yes
just do kanye west i was
i was pushing the [ __ ] out of my boys my
boy's brother had a
rap group called dilated peoples and
they had a song with kanye and they were
like big
and i used to tag their [ __ ] up on
everything yeah a little eyeball
and shout out to dilated man so what's
next for you man the pot
i know you can't do stand-up right now
really yeah it's a little tough
um are you like is that how you're
paying your bills right now
what doing stand-up because you got you
got to pay your bills
yeah i'm full time with so you're i mean
like you're getting hit pretty hard then
financially right now
not not really selling a little drugs no
no guns guns
yeah um no yeah uh in the podcast yeah
making money off that so you're doing a
podcast
full time how long have you been doing
how how long have you only been doing
content comedy where it's like the only
job you have
cause that's gotta feel good never
we're like because right now you're
full-time
oh how long have i been full-time comedy
yeah i went full-time in 2019
and i had to feel good though yeah uh
summer 2019 because um
i got on some tv show for e-network and
then i had gotten to
uh i had i had gotten into comedy
central's
fest uh comedy central festival and then
i had gotten to
one of the biggest comedy festivals in
the world uh just for last montreal
and when i got those i was just like
all right man i'm leaving this hotel job
i just like
fire yeah i double down on myself
because the way things was happening
and then all of a sudden man like once i
had quit that job
it just started like you know wow
hitting you know and then uh yeah that
just for laughs like really put me on
because that's where i
found my my touring agents and stuff
and which are uh um i would like a
really
really good so you got an agent yeah i
got a manager and you gotta holler at
my agent but no you ain't got it right
yeah i got you i got you i got you get
my agent
got it you can hit me up direct right
you got it no but yeah
like in that um ever since i got my
agent and they were
like before i even signed with them they
were like yo
we got you this kid and i saw the gig
and i was like
i'll take that because i saw i saw that
that paycheck and i was like
yeah all right but did you how often
were you on the road prior to the covet
thing
i was on yeah i was on the road a lot i
was just like
don't because you because you're
headlining too now yeah
like in different cities yeah which has
got to be because that
that festival i did have put me on the
map but what's what's been
what's been wild is that through this
covenant and being on
you know king of steam with brennan and
theo that
has like like so when i when i
yeah once this is over oh bro you get
into the bag
and then you're gonna do joe rogan and
then you're gonna and then you're gonna
be at celebrity theater with the
rotating stage oh yeah i'll do celebrity
theater
what is that like the that's like the
biggest comedy spot right
as far as like a comedy stage i mean
actually i [ __ ] wrote into george
theater or what's it called now
some other [ __ ] but that's probably
america
commercial theater that's probably the
biggest like that's where i like the
biggest
kevin hart yeah kevin hart did it um
did it uh chris i saw yeah i saw jesus
dave did it dave doesn't do like
arena's room chapelle yeah he did that
that thing with the
flight of concords do you remember oh
yeah that uh
oddball yeah and it was at um
it was at the [ __ ] on the west side
pavilion action pavilion
yeah that's great have you met dave
chappelle yet
i did i met him that's a wild story
so cause for us that's our goat yeah
chappelle show in high school
oh bruh bruh untouchable so that was
that was crazy um so i was going to
like audition like the talent director
for the comedy store would have me come
in like
every so often like kind of like
audition to see like if i wanted to move
me up to like
the next step right right um and one
night i was going in there
and uh you know
i you know i was just rolling up and i
and i turned over
to my left and i see dave chappelle and
i was like oh [ __ ] he just walked right
up to me he was like what's up man
and i was like uh i was like i'm a
comedian and my first name is chappelle
[Laughter]
and he was like hell yeah
[Laughter]
he thought it was so cool right and uh
he was like you going up man i was like
yeah you know going to be and then
the talent director had walked up saw
both of us he goes
oh my god chappelle's and i was like
that's cool that's cool
but uh then um i was like dave is it
cool like
if i get a picture with you man like i
don't know yeah yeah cause he doesn't
really do pictures
no i know i i i know this yeah so i was
like
can i get a picture with you he was like
chappelle let's take a picture
and i was like damn yeah i dj'd uh
the the after party for that show in in
phoenix
okay the one that he did in 2015 yes so
he
i went to that show so he actually
rented out my boys club
[ __ ] who's the dj he rolls with trauma
drama
yeah so my boy hits me who owns monarch
in downtown phoenix and he's like yo you
want to come and dj for de chapo and his
friends and this
it was like a monday night it was an off
night it was weird i was like what do
you mean he's like dude
him and what's the uh daniel
and no but it was also the uh the guy
who does all the roasts was there
he was a dick jeff ross oh jeff that
dude was a straight [ __ ] oh he was
a big piece of [ __ ] i was like bro
there's like 25 people here i'm like hey
what's up man you're funny and he just
looked at me like i was crazy i was like
i will
go [ __ ] you sometimes you want to just
throw hands with people yeah but yeah no
but it was kind of it was crazy because
dave i was djing and i think he ended up
hopping on or he was just telling me to
play [ __ ]
and uh he was cool as [ __ ] man he took a
picture he was when he was swole though
oh yeah when he swallowed he was jacked
and then he gave me his lighter
oh dale i forget how like uh
lit up we were a little bit blunt or
something
and then i want to give him his lighter
back and he's like just keep it
and the lighter had his logo on it and
then the c
and and the lighter said chappelle's
lighter i still got it
oh you still got it yeah of course okay
dave chappelle gave me his lighter
yeah [ __ ] and then he took a picture
with me so
yeah but i felt so weird cause look i'm
the type of guy who i'll pass on the
picture
but i'm like man this is dave chappelle
i don't know if i'm ever gonna be around
this guy again
and i don't give a [ __ ] about rappers
and musicians but like dave chappelle
it'd be like if i met
larry david like i don't care if larry
david hates my guts and i get on his
nerves
wherever he's at if i see him
he could be enjoying a meal with
children
[Laughter]
i'm gonna be like hey dude can we get a
selfie
see i'm a musician i like i geek out
over musicians
see i don't give a [ __ ] because i met
them all and i just i'm desensitized to
all this [ __ ] i i mean like
i asked you the concert question because
i don't [ __ ] all the all the
the answers to that for me are just when
i was a kid when i still cared i've been
to every single i've probably been to a
thousand concerts in my life
yeah at least a thousand i'm the same
way i've been to so many concerts
that i can't remember who i've seen and
then like now i'll go and i'll usually
be backstage
and i'll be like i just don't give a
[ __ ] to go watch i'm like yeah
brooke i've seen you 10 times yeah what
am i going to see different this yeah
yeah
you know like it's very seldomly like
where i'll see somebody for a new i'm
like oh [ __ ] yeah like mac miller was
like that like mac ever like every tour
he'd get
he'd elevate because he'd learn a new
instrument yeah dude uh
i know it's crazy because i've been
traveling so much and like
obviously if you flying in and out of
l.a like you just see
yeah people i've run into some people on
my flights and i'm like damn like
when i saw uh who was on one of my
flights schoolboy q
groovy q baby yeah i was my boy i was
like damn there he is right there bro
he's the [ __ ] too and then i was if
you're like a weirdo he'd be like yo you
a weirdo like
but he's the [ __ ] i had to say what's up
too i was like what's up cute he was
like what's up man like he was he was
cool
yeah he plays a lot of golf i saw the
baby
on the flight i didn't say what's up to
him baby's a good guy man i was like
you know because you guys seen your
videos i've seen what you do
either that or a security i was like bro
you say to your songs you ain't friendly
brother the baby killed somebody at
walmart i know like bro
like real deal i'm like bro he killed
some somebody came at him at walmart and
he smoked him
hey [ __ ] i know
nobody can say [ __ ] about that guy ever
oh no like bro
i killed somebody no one can say [ __ ]
about him or 50 or 50.
50's one of those people no one can say
[ __ ] about there's someone else i'm not
thinking of
that's gotta be oh fat joe fat joe
probably has the uh
probably the single most notorious
violence against other famous
people rap sheet and hip-hop history
really that people
like yeah oh yeah there's like fat joe
i mean yeah i remember when i first
interviewed him i was so excited
because i was like yo joe like you the
real deal fam
people don't know this because they be
hearing what's love with the shanty and
[ __ ]
but like fat joe was out here kidnapping
djs in the 90s
damn and [ __ ] getting [ __ ]
sliced up bro like
other rap like bro like cuban cuban link
the guy who was in terror squad who fat
joke or who pun put on
they ended up having a beef and cuban
link
he got his whole face cut up like fat
this whole [ __ ] got [ __ ] up oh [ __ ]
fat joe ain't the one
fat joe is not the one he had he beefed
out with a
roy jones junior at a club
they got no fear yeah fat joe's one of
them ones man noriega two nordica shot
no uh prodigy in his ass
for mobb deep yeah norris shot him
noriel was one of those guys too but now
you know nori because he's home yeah i
know yeah he's hilarious i watch his
stomach
yeah like i'll see his nose noriega back
in the day man yeah or
really [ __ ] there's some i'm trying to
think
who else is like the scariest guys where
i'm like
no no i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
you know what's funny like i definitely
think his music is horrible
and but the guy's mastered this internet
man he's funny oh but he's saying
i cannot like i'll never endorse him as
an artist
ever because he's like what he stands
for is like goes against what i came up
with and like
you know i've been around a lot of in
the street world a lot of my life with a
lot of my people and
i can't but god damn if he has not
mastered the age we're in
the trolling and the the internet like
bro this guy gets under people's skin
which is so weird it's so weird like
like he's under meek mill's skin
something crazy
and meek mill shouldn't even acknowledge
him yeah
and he's oh man it's so yeah it's so
weird to watch like when people like
when people get upset about it i'm like
y'all said it but like
you know whatever but yeah he he
he'll like yeah yeah
he dropped that video i was like
this [ __ ] is just like like a tv
series i swear to god
dude i said this before he got out of
jail like
i definitely didn't think he was going
to be like this far i knew people i knew
whatever his first look was was going to
be big
yeah but whenever they make his like
life movie about this whole trial and
like all that it's going to be fire
like he was putting hits out on people
no i was like is he untouchable right
now
i mean i think he's got uh fed security
so i think like because he's uh
technically in the uh witness protection
program but he gets out of it
in august in august but they just said
today that he he hired 22x cops
as a security ass force so he's got 22
imagine how much money that is imagine
if you're paying
a hundred thousand dollars for each one
of those guys a year and that's on the
low end
because those guys know they're signing
up for some [ __ ]
so you move you want me to go protect
the snitch you have to pay me 200 000
he's gonna spend at least five to ten
million a year on security
which is crazy makes that much money
yeah off bro i don't yeah i don't know
how the music world like
so think about it like this he got an
advance i think when he was in jail he
signed like a 25 million dollar contract
or something like that
he did when he was in jail so they knew
did the guy name is uh elliot grange he
uh is the same guy who uh
has trippy red under his label yeah so
yeah they already they
bagged them out and now you got to
realize like
the thing he [ __ ] himself on was most
rappers now make money off of
shows because like touring
yeah like touring is like probably the
biggest source of revenue for artists
okay because your music doesn't sound
like you used to yeah
but but he off the rip [ __ ] off his he
[ __ ] up
being able to go on tour because he made
enemies in every city
so he if you notice he never went on a
six night tour and he never did rolling
loud
they wouldn't book him because he was a
big liability because my boys do rolling
loud
like he never got put on those lineups
or
he never did hot 97 summer jam that's
why he was like come out and surprise
yeah they'd have to sneak him in the
venue yeah and so like he never did any
festivals
he never got his festival bag yeah he
never did a tour
he only would he'd go and do festivals
in russia
wow so like he's got to be
making i mean off of youtube and his
his music [ __ ] you would hope he's
making
i don't know dude because it doesn't
make like like i can't even make it make
sense because even if he took that 25
million
he's got to recoup that yeah so i don't
know if he
i don't know but yeah i think i don't
know dude i think the music is
his ass cheeks to be honest his music
yeah it's pretty bad
i mean yeah like there's worse music for
the record there's worse music
there's more like yeah it's not
something i
take serious but it is like it's just
not great it's like i mean like uh
it's cute like it's like tik-tok music
yeah you're just like oh okay it's just
like something catchy for the moment
what do you think of like comedians who
like are popping on social media but not
necessarily stand-up comedians
stay in their lane because there's like
guys like what like haha davis
i actually don't know those guys oh he's
fine i don't know
uh but you know what i'm talking about
there's guys yeah
those guys i've never i've never seen
their stand up so i can't necessarily
i don't think they do stand up oh they
don't i hope not i mean i don't know
let me tell you let me tell you
something i i'll tell you this
like do you like like frown frown on
those guys oh social media
no no you'll get in front of once you
get on a [ __ ] stage no
not at all because like a rapper said
you can't even [ __ ] freestyle you
know we're [ __ ] mc
no i i think it's i mean they found
they found it through that you know i
don't think it's i don't think it's
wrong i don't think it's incorrect you
know like
because you got to think you know
there's a lot of people that you know
kind of want like they want their dreams
to like to have their own tv show or
yeah be a movie the show man but you
know somehow they found this way through
the online world that they don't need a
producer these these people or anything
like that
so they just make these clips they make
these things you know which are just
entertaining
you know yeah i mean i'm entertained by
i mean a lot of the instagram guys are
so funny to me but yeah i just always
wonder like
because they're technically comedians
because they make people laugh for a
living but they're not
comedian comedians yeah they're like
they're not stand up
yeah i feel like stand up is here's the
thing about stand up
stand up is one of the hardest
things to do because you literally
the only way you can know how to do it
or not by doing it is by
doing it and you can't practice there's
no practicing with it you you
the only way to do stand-up is to do it
is to do it
in front of an audience yeah you gotta
[ __ ] up in front of everybody you gotta
that and that you have you have to
accept that and then that like
the thing is is like instagram or you
know
like you can edit your [ __ ] yeah i'm not
and then i'm not bragging all those
dudes but i'm saying that like
you can edit like you could do these
things to it to make it you know
this funny thing and there's no
stand-ups you got no
like it's right there like it's like
right in your face you know like
you're getting the judgment right there
you know that's like someone painting a
picture
and they have someone on their like
behind them just like oh
ah oh or like yeah that's tight that's
that you know what i mean like
that's what it's like you know have you
got an approach to do any specials
because netflix is doing a lot of comedy
specials
no not yet i wouldn't do one right now
you got to wait it out
yeah i'd rather get that get your weight
up a little yeah i'd rather people know
who i am like i wanted to do well
yeah yeah i don't want people like i
don't want to drop well no there's
[ __ ] some netflix specials that'll
pop them on who the [ __ ] is this guy
yeah there's some that'll like you know
i'll be like really confused like how am
i not heard of this guy i'd like to
think
that's that's just not the move i would
want to make yeah it's so
i mean yeah it sucks because like
like bill burton do a special until he
was like
i think almost i think he said almost 15
or 20 years ago
bill burr is one of my favorite
comedians man yeah
salute to bill burr man salute him shout
out to breaking bad man
bail [ __ ] bear you know what's funny
my wife i try to watch have i watched
the stand up and she always says
because my wife's mexican she always
says awesome white people [ __ ]
that [ __ ] ain't funny but guess what she
loves
f is for family oh she does and so she's
like
two seasons in and i'm like hey you know
that comedian that you hate that i try
to watch with you bill burr
she's like yeah i was like you want to
watch him tonight she's like nah i was
like let's watch
let's watch like his last one like come
on ah he's not [ __ ] funny
are you sure he's not funny are you sure
i'm sure
well you're [ __ ] he he [ __ ] is the
creator of the show you love
and he's the voice of the main and then
i was like listen to the
the the dad on that show speak yeah oh
yeah it's the same guy
yeah that's like ah [ __ ] it is him you
know what
i was like he's funny you know what's so
funny about bill burr
he got his strength and every and every
a lot a lot of comics say this
you got to do black rumors because
black rooms will give you the most
authentic reaction out of any other room
and there and they're just going to be
completely honest
if you suck and if you're good
like if you suck like i said they let
you know on site
but like if you're good they're gonna
[ __ ] you you can make
them laugh they're gonna rock with you
that's fine you know and it's
like and i think that's like the best
bill burst
got into that like where he was oh yeah
yeah yeah
that's that's like he's [ __ ]
hilarious man that's like like where he
like got like
i mean yeah it is a strange thing
because yeah like
you know what's funny is like i never
thought chris to leah stand up was that
funny
i could see that it i mean it like and i
i like his podcast like just him
watching him talk about [ __ ]
in front of his laptop but i never
thought a stand-up was that funny
and like i kind of computed that to like
this is just some white comedy like i
could understand my wife watching
christilia and being like this isn't
funny
yeah yeah yeah but i know like i could
paint you a picture of the
[ __ ] it'd be justin bieber
honestly yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's his favorite
stand-up it makes sense yeah yeah
just not for me yeah but yeah i mean
i like i said i enjoy his i mean
do you think i could cancel if i say i
enjoy his podcast it's over now
i don't know no but yeah no it's it's he
said you think
i don't [ __ ] know man yeah i mean
whatever
but yeah no it's funny because like like
you said like
i think there are certain people who are
so funny
it doesn't matter who they're in front
of yeah bill burr's university and he's
that guy
he's that guy he's universal bro
hysterical
he's universal one person like if you
can make a hood ass crowd laugh
bruh and then you can make a bunch of
trumpers laugh yeah you're a goat yeah
100 yeah which is crazy
anyway well look we're wrapping up the
podcast oh hell yeah
what is your social media oh i just do
instagram at chapelle lacey not twitter
i i have it but um like
yeah i feel you and then your your um
podcast is on youtube yeah my podcast
it's
manage which is where i talk about all
my [ __ ]
all my craziness that goes up in my head
so i don't release it are you gonna are
you
are you gonna start doing any guests or
anything no it's you
brandon yeah brendan helped me come up
with the
concept because i was like i don't know
if i want to do a podcast he was like
he goes why don't you just talk out your
journal he goes you journal every day
why don't you just talk about that [ __ ]
in there and i was like oh yeah and then
ever since i started doing i get like
this response from people like
that i didn't even think because i don't
have like i'm not pushing no agenda i'm
not doing anything like
i'm just talking [ __ ] but people just
[ __ ] with it
yeah and they say how much like it's
opened their eyes to things and like
help them like like change their lives
and like and that's crazy all that [ __ ]
and it's just me talking about like
all my internal pain that i've like
you know deal with or have dealt with
you know and just but like
i don't make it like just this somber
like you know kind of thing
it's like i make it like like i talk
about it in a fun way because yeah
you know i ain't sad well you're also a
comedian yeah
yeah exactly uh and then
what you don't know when when you guys
are going to be doing more king and
stings in person
i'm assuming oh yeah he's good now he's
good now yeah yeah okay
we recorded the other day those get
released every thursday
thursday night at nine nine uh
whatever the [ __ ] what is this pacific
pacific yeah
pacific time whatever so check you out
you're on the king of this theme park
yeah yeah it's managed chappelle lacy
yeah this was great not chappelle harris
i know that's so funny
chappelle lacy i just have i literally
haven't heard anyone
say that doing backflips yeah check
those out too